joe's joe it's not some lump of clay
that you just pound into something
congratulations on this film you guys
are both amazing
in the film the mother played by julene
bell refuses to accept that joe is trans
did you hear what i just said about joe
she said that she
is a boy you messed her up i think it's
best that you stay away
do you hope this film brings awareness
and acceptance to those types of
people out there definitely yeah of
course
what i love about the movie is it really
doesn't
you know hit you over the head with a
ball-peen hammer i mean it really is a
character-driven story about a a journey
and a real
a great journey relationship between a
father and a son
i think it sinks in deeper because you
feel for these characters these flawed
characters that are doing the best they
can
and and i think everyone can kind of
relate to that i'm in the wrong body
okay i'm a boy
sasha for you this is your first film
tell us about your character
and you know what you thought about him
when you read the script for the first
time
i was very excited to portray joe
because he was trans
and first of all i've never done any
any rules before but it was much more
exciting because
joe was trans so i could definitely
connect joe moore
i hope that people see that
there's people like them and that
there's nothing wrong with them because
they're trans now they're coming after
us
you understood what we were doing what
was the plan you were supposed to
protect me
are you ready to take hollywood by storm
is this the plan
yeah definitely okay okay that's
my plan too for 30 years now